whenever you hear something oh how could
she just know it's not even the tip of
the iceberg what you're hearing this
this is mild this is the real [__] up
part is that a lot of people want to get
books for future work so they just keep
their mouth shut about how disgusting
and dirty that industry is uh lizzo you
sent me that yeah Liz was getting
exposed apparently she out here body
shaming forcing women to put things
inside of them she's not getting exposed
she's getting sued okay she's getting
sued I'm like damn this is a big deal I
was always gonna be a career musician I
just didn't know I was going to be
yeah I thought I was an entertainment
tonight we're just gonna do a
compilation of her saying big this is a
big deal I knew I was going to make I
didn't know I was gonna be making this
big that's like I thought it was gonna
be a lot of those but thankfully they're
responsible but I'm not so editor put a
compilation a bigger
you stupid
I actually accept that was crazy I was
gonna call her Big oh I could do her the
way she did her dancers okay I don't
mind ET obtained the 38-page lawsuit
filed today among the claims lizzo who
is known for embracing body positivity
weight shamed the dancers when I was a
little girl that was a long time ago I
heard being a little girl was a long
time ago I already know the answers to
that why are you body shaming here man
if a [__] body shames then I'm a
body shaved
no honestly I was gonna do it regardless
I'm a piece of [__]
but hey hey you know I mean I just hate
these body positivity people I'm not
gonna lie
Lydia someone
fat like me
act like me beautiful like me all we
need her is to turn out to be an Uncle
Ruckus and then she gonna be the
opposite of everything she preaches
because nobody if you feel me I didn't
know I didn't know Abba was so much ear
yeah because she went into it fat like
me true big like me true and they said
beautiful like but i'm like [__] you
lying stop it right now what is this two
truth and a lie we don't need to hear
that stuff she's not ugly
it's not ugly have you seen her soul
because it's getting sued
hey guess what you wanna know the
funniest part you know who's suing her
other big beaches
okay girl all her dancers are big girls
I know because I Googled them oh wait
wait wait wait no no because I want to
see who she fed treatment
they're other big girls I thought she
was kidney shaming though no they're big
girls she's fat yeah cause all the
dancers yeah yeah it actually plays a
punt to the story that's [__] up that
is there's a positive and people were
expecting me to be Petty I'm not I'm
gonna just keep going Grammy winner who
has not yet responded to claims is also
accused of pressuring dancers to touch
nude performers unjust firings and an
excruciating 12-hour rehearsal where
there was so much fear of getting laid
off one dancer soiled her pants two of
the women were featured on lizzo's Emmy
12 hour audition sounds inhumane I'm
letting you know right now this is not
the most abnormal thing that's a
standard I would say standard but it is
not the most uncut I would say it as a
standard okay all of the women were
featured on lizzo's emmy-winning reality
show watch out for the big girls like a
month ago I was in my room sad
unemployed doing online school now I'm
here on the freaking main stage at
Treasure Island with lizzo very
important to me that of course the show
goes well but that everybody is safe and
healthy on this tour
[Music]
um yeah Legend she made these people
touch toys that were came out of nude
performers uh you know she called them
all sorts of name based out their weight
said they wouldn't cut it uh if people
spoke out she would go through her
manager to fire people
um the things that are being alleged in
terms of how she fat shame folks was
kind of wild and a lot of people are
disappointed a lot of people feel some
weight because Liza was a symbol of body
positivity that big girls can make it
you know what I'm saying hey it's [__]
up what the patriarchy does
sorry yeah it is something
hey you already know you know what I
mean right hey hey this is one of my
favorite videos of all time she got she
got some tears from this one let's take
a look
sometimes I feel like the world just
don't love me back
singer lizzo is in tears you know news
reporter shut the [__] up we can see her
crying onto you and you just want to get
your awarded single lizzo is in tears in
what looks like her back [__] we see it
on video well that's what they do no no
no no generally they give useful context
not this no they don't no they don't I
feel so down
I worked so hard
it's half phobic
it's racist and it's hurtful
it's so funny to hear a cry about this
okay uh do you need more contacts well
no not really that's not a context we
could go right in in there
what's the context you want to give no I
said we're good okay so what do you want
to say okay well the fact I thought you
were about to play video about like all
the allegations and stuff like that no I
mean if they follow the lawsuit what
harassment sexual nature uh they filed
one in regards to bad work environment
and the exposed lab what she does again
that's a lot of things that happen in
the dance industry right uh not enough
about the sex toys and stuff like that
I'm talking about the extruding
actuating uh long
auditions and stuff like that the sex
thing
uh no I wouldn't even say that's not
industry standard but that's a different
topic yo did you see me pause or no
right I'm just saying I went uh I don't
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's the
standard but
[__] it kind of is uh I love just
two separate incidents involving a
banana
Kitty wanted to eat a banana out of a
out of an ex-worker yeah that was new
today so she made her employees who were
dancers try to eat the banana and oh
okay keep going that's crazy we don't
have all the information I want to see
her side I want to see I want to wait
for proofs and stuff like that I'm
saying I want to see where this goes but
God damn lizzo if this [__] is true I
think that's career ending you think
that's Korean I think that's career
ending especially in that
in that Realm
that should be became the you became the
the the poster boy the poster child of
uh positivity
all body positivity and then you are
found that you are doing the same thing
you are frowning people it don't look
good if that's true
I think it's career ending
and the crazy thing is that even if it's
not true there's always going to be a
doubt and that's crazy I don't think
it's creating at all I think if she's
talented she's gonna put out bangers and
they're still gonna sub because the
truth is people don't really care about
fat people all right and I'm gonna be
honest with you if my artist got accused
of fat shaving uh I'd still buy his
records even if he fashioned everybody
on the planet it's actually the truth
and I think most people even if
you receive represents I think it might
hurt her brand opportunities but as far
as her touring and her fans going to her
show I promise you it's not gonna hurt
that much all the people that are
following her are very disappointed and
these people are probably gonna you know
you don't think so okay Hey listen I've
seen dudes come back from grape I've
seen dudes come back from everything
under the sun and still be able to tour
I mean R Kelly was on video peeing and
he was still selling out but we don't
know if she was really underage I'm just
saying so if you think of fat shaming
and he claim it wasn't him and also
dancers who cares these people don't
care listen here's the thing I've
already covered this in a previous video
people don't really care about dancers
they're like the lowest totem like and
I'm speaking as a dance myself they're
on the lowest end of the totem pole when
it comes to Artistic rights compensation
workplace benefits everything okay being
a dancer at the highest level you're not
making much money unless you're a
choreographer and that's only because
you tell other dancers what to do okay
honestly it's only because you treat
dancers like the lowest meaning this
egg artist you're a billionaire
I mean sure in the world
you'd be lucky to be a
ble to be a no you're a thousand there
okay you got a couple hours is this not
a profitable business because the work
is not valued first off it's ephemeral
all right on video everybody's recording
themselves on Tick Tock and it's gonna
be the top of the end of the stuff like
people don't really pain unless it's the
grand ballet and even the grand ballet
dancers don't be making money like that
except for like a select one or two so
they don't make money like it's not easy
to make money because there's such a a
um a rotating door of dancers they're
treated like trash okay that 12-hour
audition I know plenty of dangers who
went through that on tour and the whole
thing of eating the banana listen there
is no
gay industry like the dance industry now
the amount of people I know or gay for
pay to get on tour is crazy
choreographers who are diddling people
uh who are straight because they need to
get on tour demanding photos banging
dancers who don't
I'm telling you this first ain't seen it
okay so this is not surprising to me all
this stuff the reason that this never
comes out this is the real [__] up
part is that a lot of people want to get
booked for future work so they just keep
their mouth shut about how disgusting
and dirty that industry is okay I know
dancers that were sucking dick just to
be in a YouTube video of a filmed
choreography in class
straight how you straight it listen
organ dancers are desperate to make
their dreams come true you'd be
surprised how many artists go to
Hollywood who are straight and do some
such [__] just to be able to get some
clicks and some notoriety or a newspaper
article or a credit this is the dark
side of this stuff it is not exaggerated
if anything is underrepresented because
the people who do it also the people who
represent a lot of media
okay so whenever you hear something oh
how could she just know it's not even
the tip of the iceberg what you're
hearing this this is mild it's a bit
like whenever you go to high school and
then you get to high school in your
first grade of high school and you was
bullied but when you get to the top
grades of high school you bully people
so all the dealing and stuff like that
when you got it was done to you but then
when you get in that position you kind
of do it again because it's a circle of
life and people like what you're saying
is a hundred I don't know if it's that
much of a circle what she's exposing
these dancers to she's probably never
been exposed to as far as eating bananas
out of EX workers or whatever
that you talked about talk about what
you spoke about how she spoke about
about the diddling like they go in there
they start dancing and they want to get
they want to advance they want this they
want that and once they get to that
position if they get to that position
they sometimes do the same thing do you
think also why this story is coming out
specifically
um this is just it's kind of hard but
it's true the dancers for lizzo big
girls
uh you heard one of the girls say it
herself she was on her couch and then
all of a sudden she's performing a
message once lizzo fired them these
women are not getting more work
so a lawsuit's pretty much the only
thing they got left as far as the
industries and y'all can get mad I don't
really care but go look at every touring
artist right now and see how many of
them got big girls on they line up lizzo
was the only one so these women can
afford to do that the other women who
saw it there's actually a few women who
commented who said I saw this stuff
happen but I'm not part of the lawsuit
you know they're just trying to be able
to protect their future work opportunity
so dancers will undergo and tolerate so
much nastiness and so many nasty things
just to be able to get a little bit
further ahead as far as artists goes
there's a lot of Romancing in the in
that industry what it should be in the
ideal of it you know the glamorize of
the dancer world you travel you dance
you perform in front of the dark side is
dark and it's real
and it's hot and it's nasty
when it tastes like bananas I don't like
bananas they could do whatever the hell
they want and say uh you can be
beautiful at always I know that if I'm
30 pounds heavier
I'm dying yeah
oh this is I can't be so or whatever
everybody does their thing this is one
of those things where when I see this
unfold I'm like is it surprising no not
really it's just a cute headline it's
like finding out the cat yeah it's a
cute headlight it's like finding out the
pastor doodle the kid like is that
shocking at this point no not really no
no you know so I'm gonna give Alyssa
this like all the people that are
shocked I feel like y'all should know a
little bit better now how many times
does a celebrity have to betray your
fact that they're not the image they
portray you guys would be shocked how
many artists that you guys love today
are [__] horrendous to the people
that work under them how many times I
gotta talk to people and tell them
Lauren Hill's one of the worst people to
work under and if you guys don't believe
me you can look at all the artists
who've worked under her and who's like
been on tour with her they'll say like
she's a [__] dictator with the way
that she runs things and not in a I'm
working hard just like crazy [__]
Jennifer Lopez I know would fire People
based off their astrological sign I
think it's going to be solved outside of
Court they're not gonna do a court thing
with them I mean you might as well get
your paycheck these big girls never
gonna be on stage again no they're not
well well they not well I mean they not
you guys use the body requirements to be
on tour with some of these artists
there's literally no lawsuit or no what
you mean lawsuits are no lawsuit they
would not be unsafe like they got fired
they got fired any thoughts on body
positivity ah no not really okay all
right I think the movement is a bit
weird sometimes what I heard some some
weird stuff
and the dumbest [__] comes from young
people
and when they're older I really I really
like suspect them of no you're taking
advantage of something because you know
it's not exactly that but you gotta
digress yeah that's all I gotta say let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you
what do you guys think about Bingo and
all our issues going on uh and that's
pretty much it for today's video Boom by
the way we sold out the Washington soap
I think Pittsburgh got like 10 tickets
and Detroit got a few left as well so if
you're coming out to one of the shows
don't miss out on your chains because
right now the tickets are almost all
gone oh and then we're gonna do the rest
of the tour dates sometime in the winter
so don't worry all you other people when
they'll come in Australia we come in
don't don't
going to see our big old booties okay
you want to see big old in flesh all
right hey I've been preach but yeah
don't try to knock it up there's nothing
don't DM yeah I want to tell him take
don't don't